point des pères aux anses d'arlet dès 7
heures du matin les bénévoles du jour
sont déjà au charbon leur mission tout
nettoyer mais vraiment tout de la petite
bouteille en verre en passant par la
grande gazinière usagers et des déchets
il y en a pas mal
alors pas de répit pour ceux qui se
chargent de tout retirer aujourd'hui
comme il y avait une grande solidarité
avec tous les deux les autres personnes
donc je me suis dit pourquoi ne pas y
aller
voilà vous êtes réveillé à quelle heure
ce matin pour pouvoir être présente dès
6 heures des arlésiens mais aussi des
vacanciers sont mobilisés pour la cause
avant la fin du mois la ville doit être
propre
pour le tournage de cette émission le
village préféré des français
le village préféré des français mais à
partir du 31 janvier les projecteurs sur
les anses d'arlet stéphane bern et son
équipe sillonneront la commune pour le
tournage de l'émission les
téléspectateurs découvriront donc le
patrimoine et les particularités des
anses d'arlet s'il faut faire de
nettoyage ont fait de nettoyage ans pose
pas de questions il faut qu'on gagne
pour le senti dans les terres comme aux
abords des plages le nettoyage se
poursuit non sans difficultés mais la
détermination de certains arrivent à
venir à bout des tâches les plus
compliqués
c'est une opportunité indéniable knox l
affaire de tous les arts béziers donc
nous mobilisons toute la population pour
à nouveau rendre plus belle la vie
puisque ne l'est déjà bien sûr
au pied de l'église c'est un tout autre
travail d'embellissement qui est en
cours attention peinture fraîche le
message hordinois ici on se prépare
comme il se doit pour espérer remporter
l'édition 2020 du village préféré des
français